So we'll wait for a couple of
moments and then we'll get
started.
You also get a chance to look at
the notebooks, or at least the
place where it is.
Let me bring it here.
Yeah, just let me know once the
browser is visible.
Those are course Canvas page and
you see the updated list here
right?
So yesterday I had only one, but
yesterday we learned about
stacks, queues, sling list and
so on.
So those notebooks are also
available here.
And again, a word of caution for
all of you.
Don't use this discussion forum.
Yeah.
So this discussion is for
something that is common.
Yeah, for example, you need
something about the exams or
say, textbooks or something like
that, right?
So for all those exercises and
other things that we are doing
in our class, which is our
section specific, you need to go
into this section Section 1 and
then you have this discussion
inside and you need to be using
this one, yeah.
Yeah, Krishna says check the
place but not the.
Yeah, that's fine.
Yeah, but as long as you know
where it is, you can of course
explore that in the coming week.
So to be as a question and
wrapped around queue, what is
the place of rare end?
The last element index or the
next element, the next Mt index.
Yeah.
So that's the same concept
across in queue.
Rare will always point to the
next available cell, if at all
there is some available, right.
If there is nothing available,
then it will also point to some,
you know, save the whole wrapped
around is full.
It might have gone to the zeroth
position, and if nothing has
been deleted, then in the zeroth
position something will also be
there, right?
Yeah.
OK, I'll have a look at that.
Yeah, there's some discussion
thread.
Yeah, that's already there.
Yeah, Batra in this deck in
appendix.
And not spend too much on that.
That's one application that is
for you, but of course that will
also be covered briefly in the I
know baby now. Yeah.
So you have a webinar coming up
so.
Know why doesn't it work?
It does work right.
You do r + 1 mod N and that
would take you back to the
beginning of, so you'll do R + 1
mod N and in that position you
will insert the item right.
So this is similar to your
stacks top right, so there you
do.
You go to the next position and
then you insert it, whereas in
queue you will insert it and
then perform this r + 1, yeah.
The slight difference between
them.
We'll wait for another minute
and then we'll get started.
So it's the same concepts Ruby.
It's just like R Plus plus or,
you know R is equal to r + 1,
but just that since it is
rounded you want to go back to
the initial position if you have
already hit the threshold,
you're using that mod and yeah.
So last class we just, you know
recapped and started with you
know stacks and so on and then
we learned about a lot of simple
you know pseudo codes and also
some demos and so on.
And there was this application
of how do you evaluate a postfix
expression, right?
And then we went to queues and
queue had this problem of what
if there are, you know some
numbers that you have inserted
and you have deleted all of
them.
But if you are rare reaches the
end, it will complain that there
is no more space in the queue.
But of course there can be space
in the beginning, so it all
instead of doing this, let's
have a wrap around configuration
which is called as a circular
queue, right?
So in this case also, if you see
through, we currently rare is at
5 and if I want to insert an
element here say suppose 500, I
will insert the element right
here that is in queue of rare I
will insert it and then I would
do rare is equal to rare plus
one mod N so in this case what
would happen R is equal to rare
plus one will become five plus
1/5 plus one is 66, modulus 8 is
6 only.
So you will point here.
So the next step when something
else has to be inserted, you
will directly insert it at that
position, which is in queue of
where you'll insert that element
there.
Then you will perform rare,
equal to rare plus one mod N
that will become 6 + 1 mod 8
that is 77 mod 8 is 7 only, so
you'll go to this position
right?
So you will be pointing there.
So the very next time when you
want to insert directly, you
will put it there and then you
will again increment.
So at that time it will become 7
+ 1 mod 8 which is 8 mod 88.
Mod 8 is 0, so you would have
come here.
Yeah.
Does it make sense?
So if you see the code here,
there is a slight difference
here.
Right in, in Q, you actually
first put the item right.
You first put the item because
it will always point to an empty
location, right?
Unless the full queue is full.
Yeah, it will point to the empty
cell where you actually put the
item and then you perform or
equal to R + 1 mod N Yeah, I'll
recommend you to trace this
program.
Yeah.
Like take some circular queues
from the beginning, you know,
try to insert items and so on
and then it'll be more clear.
Right.
And then we learned about, you
know, it has a lot of
applications.
Yes, Sir.
So why are we doing this one?
Uh, same with this also, right?
So here also in front also if
you keep deleting right.
So for example hundred I deleted
300, I deleted 250, I deleted
and 400 I deleted 200.
I deleted.
I kept on deleting all of them
and then what about 7 right?
So suppose in the 7th item I
deleted it and now say suppose
rare had occupied all these
spaces and again since zeroed
have been empty right?
Since I deleted 103 hundred 250,
these places are empty, so Ray
would have started filling them
again.
So in that case in front also I
should be doing front plus one
mod 8 right?
Only then he will again go back
to 0, otherwise he'll just be in
seven and then he'll go to 8-9
and so on.
I waiting the picture so we so
if it delete all of these then
front is moving forward right
from friend zero it goes to 1234
and so on.
So similarly, when hit hit
seven, it has to again come back
to 0, right?
So there also I need to be
having not just front equal to
front plus one.
I need to have this model.
Yeah.
Same concept with both of them,
rare and friend, because
otherwise rare around will be
rotating but friend will go get
stuck here right?
So that should not happen.
Both of them should be rotating
across.
So for both of them we need that
mod.
And then we learned about some
applications of queue.
That is, you know, it's
absolutely needed our you know
operating system uses and even
our programming.
You know, we use it in a lot of
places, right.
And again, this scheduling and
then heaps and so on, it is
being used.
Then we started with list with
very simple concept.
Don't make it complicated.
There are many operations that
are possible in list.
It's a very exhaustive list, but
we are not learning all of them,
but it's trivial.
So what exactly is this singly
linked list, right?
It is as simple as a couple of
notes which are linked together
to form a list right?
For example, if each kid are
holding their hands in two
directions right, that becomes
like a doubly linked list.
If a list of kids are holding
their hands in one, you know
direction, then that is a singly
linked list.
So each node has two parts, one
is the actual element and one is
the pointer to the next one.
This is more like a single
linked list, but you have the
actual element A and then a
pointer to the next node.
You have the actual element B,
the pointer to the next node and
so on, whereas here we saw that
there's a problem is if I'm in a
particular node, I can only go
in the forward direction.
I cannot go reverse right?
Say if I'm in CI cannot go back
to B or A because I have lost
that address.
I don't know where should I go
to go back, right, so that is
why we have doubly linked list
which is even more powerful
where each compartment or each
node has three compartments,
right?
One is the actual element, one
is the pointer to the previous
node and one is the pointer to
the next node, right?
For example, if you are in this
frog, you can go back using this
particular you know previous
address, you can go to the next
node using the next address you
have the actual element also
there right?
So in this way you will be able
to go forward or backward, which
is more powerful for us.
And of course there's a special
header and trailer nodes also to
just keep track of who's the
first node address and who's the
last node address right?
What is pointer memory address
to the next element?
Yes, exactly right.
So it's my understanding right
singly has one address and
doubly has two address, correct?
Exactly.
That's right, yeah.
And then we also saw about, you
know, and this gives us this
complete power of dynamically
growing, right?
So we are not constrained by
memory.
So if I want to add a new node
for example, I want to now add a
cat right?
I'll create that particular node
wherever I have space and
memory, right?
I'll just create that.
I'll put that element part to
be, you know, holding the
element cat.
I've created that somewhere in
the memory, but currently that
is an orphan, right?
I'll have to add it into this
linked list right?
So suppose after this you know,
say frog or somewhere in between
or after the you know line I
need to add it.
Then I need to do a couple of
things.
That is what we learned
yesterday that I need to update
the new nodes previous to point
to.
This particular you know tiger
element, this node and the next
element will point to this one
and then what else should I do?
I would have liked this new note
to this link list, whereas this
tigers next position and this
ones previous will still be
pointing to them.
I should be making them to point
to this new cat element, right?
So that's what we learned,
right?
You create a new node 5
operations.
You do that is you create it and
put the element X.
You update this nodes previous
you update this node's next and
then in the actual englist you
update the corresponding next
and previous positions.
Then you would have successfully
inserted this element.
Likewise, you can keep you know,
extending as much as possible,
and whenever you don't want, you
can just knock them off and
knocking off was even simpler
where you just delete it the
next 10 previous alone will get
changed, the need of header and
trailer is to just know so that
we can just, you know, traverse
in both the directions, right?
I should know from where this
linked list starts right in
memory, so that is why I have
the header.
So if I want to traverse, I will
take the header that I'll get
the first nodes address.
From there, I'll keep jumping
and I can keep traversing in the
forward direction.
But what if I want to do in the
reverse?
Then I'll catch hold of the
trailer.
I'll have the address of the
last note.
I'll take that.
I'll go there to the last node.
From there, I'll take that
node's previous go to C then
I'll go to B.
Then I'll go to, and so on,
right.
It just gives us the flexibility
those two are just variables.
Yeah, header and trailer are
just variables to keep track of
in which direction to traverse.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yes, in single English we will
just have the trailer alone in
the IT is not very clearly shown
here, but there will be just a,
you know, not a trailer, just a
header node which will have the
address of this first node,
right?
Is it clear case all of you
simple stuff and we learned that
insertion and deletion are
pretty, you know,
straightforward if you are doing
it at the head or tail, right?
If you're adding it to the first
position, then it is just
constant and deletion.
Also, if you are deleting the
first node or at the last node
then it is, you know just big of
1 because you just have the
header and trailer.
You can just go to the
headdress, delete them or add
them there, right?
But the problem is if you want
to access somewhere in the
middle or if you want to
traverse it then it is a big
off.
Again, MANOJNA sinto.
We don't know where the expected
object is, so we do have
relocation correct?
So basically you want to
traverse guys, right?
So if you don't have this
trailer node right, you don't
have this trailer node you want
to go to D then what is the only
way?
Manoj, you'll have to start from
the beginning.
You'll catch hold of this first.
You know header node, you'll go
to a, then B, then C then D
which is big O of N complexity,
whereas always if you maintain
the last nodes address also in
some special variable called
trailer you can use this to
directly go to D right.
The complexities we go of 1 now,
right?
So it just gives us some
flexibility that in both ways
I'll be able to traverse.
That's pretty much right.
Full.
There's also some small two
slides that had skipped
yesterday that is, uh.
We learned about stacks using an
array, right?
Yeah, this is again a question.
How do we know these?
Uh, near to trailer?
Yeah, we don't know.
That's just a chance that you
want to take, or if you want to
reverse traverse in that way,
definitely this is going to help
me, right.
If I want to travel the whole
enlist in reverse, I want to
know from you know the last
element to 1st then always this
is going to help me but Tyler
node right?
It just gives me the power that
in both directions I'll be able
to hit the notes right.
In some cases, people will have
a doubly linked list without the
trailer.
Also, that is also fine if you
the the most important part is
in every node, you should have
those two compartments previous
and next.
This is more or less, you know,
a designers choice if they want
to maintain a trailer node or
not.
Yeah.
So a general practices if there
is a doubly linked list, it will
have both the head and trailer
node.
The head node will always have
the address of the first node,
and as and when you keep adding
nodes, the last nodes address
will always be there in the
trailer node.
If you have just inserted one
item, in that case we'll header
and trailer be the same.
Yeah, you have created a doubly
linked list which has just one
node.
Currently, yeah.
So in that case, we'll header
and trailer will both of them
point to the same one?
Yes, it will be the same.
Yeah, because you just have one
node which is the first one,
which is the last one.
But if you add another node B
then header will point to the
first node, which is a trailer
will point to the last node
which is B. Cool.
Fine.
So we also learned about stacks
using array and Q using array
and we learned that you know the
whole disadvantage of array is
coming to stack.
So you can also implement a
stack using a linked list.
Also something like this right?
For example, what you can do is
you can make the nodes to be
your stack element right?
For example, this is pointing to
Rome.
This is to Seattle and so on,
and you will decide this trailer
node or tail node to act as your
top right.
So only in One Direction you
will keep adding and only in
that direction you will keep
removing meaning now only this
tail can be removed.
Only this Toronto can be removed
and once you remove it you will
be back to this particular
Seattle.
If you remove Seattle, you'll
come back to Rome.
So basically the head or the
tail of the list could serve as
the top of the stack.
Yeah.
Is everyone understanding this
part?
So basically if you want to
implement a stack that concept
that is your, you know last in
first out concept using the
linked list you will just create
a singly or doubly linked list.
But you will ensure that only
only One Direction you can add.
Now you cannot add in between
this room and Seattle, or
between Seattle and Toronto, or
you cannot delete Rome.
All that options are now gone
because now you are implementing
a stack using a linked list.
So the only option that you can
do is you can keep adding in one
end that is at the tail end, or
if you want to delete you just
delete that element pointed by
tail, which is nothing what your
top of stack.
Yes, no.
Can you just quickly, you know,
I don't see any replies.
You'll get.
How do you implement a stack
using a linked list to search a
particular element in English?
How can we decide whether to go?
You have to go it from the head
itself.
Yeah.
So you're getting too confused.
You can start with either from
you know, head or trailer.
It is the same complexity which
has big of yen that don't worry
about it.
So this this is another concept.
Either you can take tail or you
can take head, meaning in that
case the link list will grow in
the left side direction.
You'll keep adding here.
You know in this side you will
keep adding, right, Krishna,
either you can start adding and
you you are growing it from left
to right, right.
Otherwise you can add it in this
deck.
Similarly for Q you will have a
enough simple linked list.
You will have both head and tail
now coming into action when you
want to keep adding some
element, you will add it in the
tail end and when you want to
delete something you will
increment your head.
So now in this diagram, can
someone point me to what is head
equal into in queue? And you
also we had two variables right?
So if you consider this diagram,
what is tails equivalent and
what is head equivalent?
Ask him what it means.
Bang on that is friend.
Yeah, head is nothing but your
friend and tail is nothing but
your rare right.
So you will keep adding in this
direction and you will keep
deleting from this direction.
And since this is a linked list,
there is no problem of circular
or all this because I can keep
adding even you know I don't
have next location available, I
can go and create a node
anywhere in memory and then I
will link it here.
So there is no problem of that
space constraint here, right?
This is exactly what we
discussed yesterday, and there's
this appendix for all of you who
were asking how to convert in
fix and so on.
There is this algorithm.
There is 2 examples I have given
right, so very clear example
right and you can go about
trying this and there's also
some exercises and for this also
there is already a URL you can
put this in.
Get your solutions right.
So try to solve these two and
you know try to, you know, get
the hang of this.
If it is still not clear, please
let me know the next class we
will try to cover this concept
also in the first webinar.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
Yeah.
What will be the order of delete
same like your queue right?
So you'll have to keep
incrementing your friend in this
case, which is nothing but your
head.
You'll just increment 1 by 1.
Right, you cannot delete
something in the middle or all
there because you're
implementing a queue using your
linked list, right?
It will follow the queue
principle.
That is first in, first out.
It's not all good.
Tell you.
Proceed to today's.
Yeah.
Yuvarajan question why previous
node node there is implementing
queue stack.
So basically you can implement
stack or queue using two things
guys.
Either you can use a linked list
or an array.
We discussed about array
completely in the last class and
it had certain disadvantages.
That is, you cannot extend
dynamically or shrink it
dynamically, so we use somehow
the linked list in order to
achieve the same concept.
Yeah, there's nothing more
complex to it.
And because you're using it, you
have the inherent property of
linked list also.
That is, you have, you know,
enter to the next node and so
on.
Yeah, cool.
I would recommend you to you
know solve those appendix
questions.
Otherwise, we will just be in
the stack concept even you know
one application is not there in
the course handout.
But I thought, you know, it's
important.
You know the applications of
these, that is where I had
covered that you know postfix
evaluation, but for infix to
postfix I will recommend that
you know you look at the slide
and you know practice them and
if you are not able to
understand it just you know post
a note or you know let me know
in the next class and we will
cover it in the 21st December
maybe in our yeah.
So we go of one way CR.
So if you want to add something
in the beginning or you know at
the end, you know since you have
header node, it is complexities
constant.
Otherwise it is we go off then
because you have to traverse and
then insert, yeah.
I'll again recommend your batch.
All the recording so far.
Please watch them again and
again because they're all very
related.
Yeah, we learned about what is
bigger of and what is constant
time complexity and so on in the
very first and second class,
right.
They'll all be related.
So today, what will be learning
is related to last class right
then since it was just yesterday
it is fine but from the next
week onwards, at a point where
you will reach I will show you
an algorithm which uses all 15
classes concept right?
So that is why it is very
important that you keep
revisiting what we have learned
so far, right?
Cool.
That being said, welcome to the
4th contact session for data
structures and algorithm design,
and today we will start a new
topic which is price right?
To recap of last class, that is
exactly what we did so far,
right?
We learned about stacks, queues,
arrays, link list, the power of
linked list, right, doubly
linked list, singly linked list
and so on.
All those we have learned, but
so far all those data structures
that we learned.
What is 1 common property among
them?
Can you real quick let me know
what is the common property
among all of them?
Yeah, between array stack Q link
list right it is a linear data
structure right?
Whether in memory or not, that
is fine, but they're all linear
in nature, right?
But it's in every use case that
might not be true.
There might be cases where I
need to store data in a
nonlinear fashion, right?
That is why we have other
concepts like trees.
We will learn about, you know,
tree terminology, the different
types.
How do you represent a tree and
traverses, and so on, and we
will close the class for today,
right?
So we have studied all this,
that is array linked list,
stacks, queues and so on and
they were all ideally more like
a linear or if you want to
visualize more like a straight
line, right?
But how do you obtain
relationships, right?
For example, in your
organization, are you all in a
flat organization where everyone
is, you know, linear?
Can I just place all of you in a
list?
Yeah.
If you are, then you are in a
lucky org.
Yeah, but most probably there is
a CEO.
There's a board member, there
are vice presidents, directors,
managers and then you know there
are employees.
Then you have interns.
And things like that.
So.
So when was telling that this is
a hierarchy, right?
So how do you represent
hierarchical data?
That is where trees are coming
into play.
But before that, how should one
choose which data structure to
use, right?
So there are plenty of ways.
That is what needs to be stored.
You'll have to first of all look
at the data, right?
Is it linear in nature or is it
having some relationship like
hierarchy in them right?
Or is there something like, you
know, a network type of relation
where many people can be related
to many other people?
Is there something like that?
Things like that.
Firstly, you need to have a look
at what is going to be stored
and then the cost of operations,
right?
So what Operation am I going to
do?
A lot of times right is it
insert.
Usually that is happening or is
it more of a search that is
happening or which type of
operation I'm doing most and you
will ensure that you will choose
such a data structure which has
that operation as a good
complexity, right?
And then the memory use and of
course the ease of
implementation.
So these are some guiding
principles on which data
structure you will choose.
Right?
So, not nonlinear data
structures, right?
So linear access time of linked
list is still expensive, right?
So does there exist any simple
data structure for which the
running time is, you know, log
in so far?
Have we learned any data
structure for which all the
operations insert, delete,
search all of them is login?
Have we learned anything like
that?
So we will continue this search,
OK, this is more like a treasure
hunter.
We want a data structure which
is going to give us log N
complexity.
So by the way, log N is good or
bad.
The very first class constant
log N log NN square N cube.
Yeah, it is good.
So now we are looking at.
I wanted it a structure for
which all these operations,
inserting, deleting, searching
all of them are log N thought we
have not learned anything about
that right stack Q link list.
All of them are giving me big of
yen in some or the other
operation.
I want some data structure which
will give me log in, but let's
see.
Let's see who is going to give
us.
Yeah, let that search continue
and before the end of the
semester, we'll get an answer
for that.
So trees will learn the basic
concepts, traversals and all
those.
But first thing first, trees are
going to store elements
hierarchically, right?
And the top element is called as
the root.
There are several examples,
right?
The family structure, family
tree, directory structure,
organizational structure and so
on.
So this is an actual view of a
tree.
Do you agree you have the root
at the bottom and then you have,
you know, branches coming out
and then you have the leaves,
right?
This is a normal view of a tree,
but what is a computer scientist
view of a tree?
Yeah.
If you just reverse this right
so always you have the root at
the top and then from the root
you have branches coming down
and then you have the leads,
yeah.
So a tree is a hierarchical data
structure or abstract data type.
Why is it abstract data type?
Because again, we are going to
use either array or linked list
in order to implement it, right?
It is more of a high level
concept.
You can implement it using
underlying data structures, so a
tree or upside down is an
abstract model of a hierarchical
structure.
A tree consists of nodes with a
parent child relationship.
Yeah, very important.
It is having a parent child
relationship and that is how you
are now bringing in that
hierarchy here each element
except the Tom element has a
parrot and zero or more children
elements.
So for example, if you consider
here laptop is having a parent
which is manufacturing and
manufacturing is again having a
parent computer ours.
Similarly for Asia, it is
international sales computer and
so on.
So apart from this topmost one,
everyone else has a parent,
whereas this one doesn't have a
parent and all of them have zero
or more children, right?
For example, this Europe, Asia,
Canada, etcetera, do they do not
have any children, right?
Whereas manufacturing has two
children, right?
International has three children
and so on.
So what is the tree again?
So a tree is a finite non empty
set of elements, right?
It is finite in nature.
It is non empty and it is going
to represent a hierarchical
structure.
It consists of parent child
relationship.
So again, here.
Yeah, if you are able to, you
know, have a look at this.
This is the root.
It doesn't have any parent.
Everyone else has a parent, and
some people have one child.
Some people have no child.
Some people have two child and
so on right.
There are plenty of applications
of tree, right?
Your organizational data can be
represented as a tree.
Your file systems right?
Your file system itself, Linux
and so on, use a tree structure,
right?
And many programming languages,
right?
Your compiler or your ID is also
use them.
We look at a couple of examples,
right, so let's stack you, et
cetera, linear in nature,
whereas if you want to, you
know, convey hierarchical
representation, you need trees,
right?
I don't know about you, but at
least I use this.
For example, say you have root,
then you have home.
Then you can have, say, bits
inside bits.
You might have, say first
semester in first semester you
might have four folders for you
know for courses inside that you
might save all the you know
presentations and all that.
Yeah.
Is there anyone who does that?
Yeah, you have a folder called
bits.
Inside that you have 4, you know
first semester and then you know
all your courses inside the
courses you have your slides and
so on.
Right.
So inherently you're actually
using a tree, correct?
So you have the topmost which is
the root.
Then you have some folder.
Then you have some 4 subfolders
and so on.
So there your slide becomes you
know, a child of your DSD, DSD
itself is a child of your first
semester and 1st semester is a
child of your bits folder or
something like that, right?
So in Linux this is very common.
So this thing all slash and home
and so on, right?
So this itself is a tree
structure moves in a game.
Yeah.
So there are games like Tic Tac
toe and so on, which you can
represent using a tree
hierarchies and organization and
so on.
Even an index right in many
textbooks, if you have seen, you
might have seen an index like
this right features of object
orientation is a textbook name.
You have chapter one
introduction, Chapter 2,
encapsulation, Chapter 3,
polymorphism, Chapter 4,
inheritance and so on.
So these chapter names have
become the first level children,
right?
This is the textbook name.
These are all the chapter names
inside that you have subsections
like vocabulary and topics which
become its children, right?
So an index can be translated
into a tree like this.
Yeah.
Is it clear case all of you it's
actually speaking this left hand
side is also hierarchical
representation only.
Yeah.
So this a is inside introduction
and introduction is inside this
textbook, right?
So there is inherently some
hierarchy here.
So we are now here making more
explicit and drawing it like a
tree.
Yeah.
Your typical organizational
example right there are some
managers they report to VP of
Finance.
He reports to VP of
manufacturing.
They all report to the
President, but the President
has, you know, an assistant and
so on, right there is hierarchy.
There are trees.
Even an arithmetic expression,
right?
So we'll not go too deep into
it.
I just want to throw some light
that you know, what are the
applications, but if you have
learned about courses like
compiler designs, right.
Has anyone done all those
courses right?
How to create your own compiler
right?
So it's a very traditional, you
know, typical number assign
scores and you will learn that
you know your compilers actually
draw trees like these, right?
And it will verify if your
statement is correct or not.
Otherwise, it'll have some
mistakes in the tree, right?
It will want to know ambiguities
in this statement, so it'll
actually translate this
expression into a tree like
this, right?
So they're also trees are being
used, right?
And many compilers represent a
program itself as a tree that
also couple of them do right.
So if then condition then you
know statement and so on.
It can also translate that into
A3 type of a structure, right?
So far so good, all of you.
Just the motivation of what is a
tree data structure.
It is a hierarchical data
structure.
It is used to represent
hierarchical data, right?
So far so good and all these
type of different applications,
right?
Wherever there is some inherent
hierarchy we should be using the
tree data structure, and now
what we will do is, yeah, yeah.
Which content?
Yeah, that is fine.
Yeah, if you are understanding
what are the applications that
is good enough, I would
recommend you to go deep into
all this if you're interested.
Yeah.
How are expression trees created
so on you can actually go about
learning it but not you know,
too deep into it because that is
more of a CS, you know, not more
like a data structure thing or I
mean your data science thing.
So now what we will do is there
are a lot of terminologies for
trees.
Yeah, across the semester in
your question papers in the
normal you know, just like your
we're talking, we will be using
a lot of terminologies and we
need to be very, very clear with
these, right.
So we'll spend some time on it.
I'll go one by one and I'll also
keep asking you questions.
Yeah, let's do this.
Yeah, all of you.
Are you here?
Yeah, because this is very, very
vital.
So I'll not be repeating this in
the further classes, we will
just learn this here and make it
very clear.
Right.
I'll go one by one.
I'll go a little slow.
Yeah.
Approved.
What is the root?
An old without a parent is a
root.
Yeah, in this particular tree, A
is the root, right.
Again, a word of question.
So these bracketed terms,
whatever I have, is a couple of
examples.
They are not exhaustive in
nature, so don't go that.
Only these are the answers,
right?
So I've taken some examples.
Now I have a question for you.
In a tree, how many root can be
there?
Yeah, we already saw the
definition of tree.
Yeah, very good.
Only one can be there, the top
most element.
Who doesn't have a parent is
called as a root, so there can
only be one root in a tree.
Simple siblings.
Note that share the same parent
are called siblings, so BCD are
all sharing the same parent.
ASOBCD are siblings.
Can you name some other siblings
in this tree?
Yeah.
GNH their siblings, ENFP, they
are also siblings.
IJK.
They're all siblings, right?
Perfect internal node node with
at least one child is called an
internal node, right?
He has children, so it is an
internal node, so the root is
also an internal node.
In this case, right, we we also
has children.
C also has children.
F also has children, right?
So anyone who has at least one
child, also, they become a
internal node.
Alright, what about external
node?
Node is also having another name
called Leaf.
It is something which does not
have any children, right?
For example, in this case E, it
doesn't have any children IJK,
they do not have any children.
What about B GH?
They do not have any children,
so they are called as external
nodes, or they're also called
less leaves nodes.
Yeah.
So internal node is another node
of for root, no no, not at all.
Root is the top most element,
which doesn't have a parent.
That's all right.
So a root can be an internal
node, but all internal nodes are
not roots, right?
So in this example, B is also an
internal node because it has
children.
C is also an internal node.
It has children, but they are
not roots, only as root, yeah.
Pull ancestors ancestor of a
node is nothing but the parent,
grandparent, great grandparent,
et cetera.
So far, EB is the parent is the
grandparent, so I can call B,
Nas and sisters of E so now you
will tell me who are the
ancestors of K.
Who are the ancestors of key?
Yeah.
FBA.
That's absolutely right.
What about descendant?
Yeah.
So as I told, this is not a
complete exhaustive examples EN
Fr siblings.
Someone had asked a question EN
Fr.
Of course siblings because they
share the same parent.
Cool.
OK, what is the descendant
descendant is exact opposite,
child, grandchild, great
grandchild, et cetera for B EFI,
JKR descendants, right?
For BE is also descendant
because it is a child, F is a
child.
IJK are all grandchildren,
right?
So all of these are the
descendants of B.
So now you will tell me who are
the descendants of C.
Yeah, G&H perfect.
What is a degree?
Yeah.
And I have another thing for
you.
What is the descendant of D?
Yeah.
The lamb, seeing only GH, yeah.
Yeah, all our answer.
All are descendants of a, right?
Well, that is the root.
Yeah, nothing is there for me,
right?
So can I now give a new
definition that a node which
doesn't have a descendant is a
leaf node?
Yeah, CD are also ancestors of E
so C and no, they are not
ancestors.
Yeah.
So Krishna, just follow the
definitions.
It should be the same line,
right?
It should be the parent,
grandparent and so on.
So CNDR not even related to E
right, though that should not be
the case.
So now what is the line that I
told?
I told nodes who don't have a
descendant.
They are leaf nodes.
Am I right in that Anita, for
example G HHD?
They don't have descendants, so
they're also a leaf node, so
that is why I'm again again
telling there are plenty of
definitions for these in many
resources.
If you go online or see books,
you might see plenty of
definitions.
Don't get confused, right?
So for leaf node you can say a
node without children, or you
can say a node without any
descendant or there are other
definitions also.
I'll tell you those.
Yeah, we'll go next one degree.
You cry of a node is the number
of its children, right?
Number of children for a it is
3.
Three children are coming out.
What about F3?
Children are coming out.
What about C?
Only two?
What about B?
Yeah, for ENFJ car not
descendants, Amit for B, they
are the descendants for E there
is no descendant at all.
Yeah, for me there are two is
the degree cool?
What does the degree of J?
Yeah.
What is the degree of J?
Zero.
So can I again now give a new
definition, a node whose degree
is 0?
Is it a leaf node?
Yes, right.
A node whose degree 0 means it
doesn't have any children, so
he's again a leaf node.
Cool.
What is the depth of X?
Yeah, very, very important.
These two.
Yeah, 90% of students get it
wrong.
Plenty of resources have it
wrongly documented.
Yeah.
A couple of additions of books
are wrong.
Yeah, so don't get it wrong.
Let me be very clear on this
depth of X.
Meaning this X can be any node.
Yeah, I can point this X to be
any of the node.
It is the number of edges in the
path from root to that X.
So for example, if I take this F
right, I should come all the way
from the root till that
particular node and see how many
lines are there in between them
or edges.
So to go to F from root, what is
the only path I love to come
from the root a I'll have to
come to B and from B I'll have
to come to F right?
So that is 1 right?
And that too is called as the
depth of F.
Yeah.
Yeah, mate.
Yeah.
So let's clarify.
There are a couple of doubts,
Amit for BE&FIJK
descendants.
Yeah, the slide says for B, what
are all the descendants?
EFI JK, that is what is written
here.
Yeah.
Is that clear, Amit?
Yes. No.
And a node cannot have two
parents.
A node can have only one parent
pull, so it's depth clear for
all of you what is the depth of
K.
Yeah, let me know the thought
process.
How are you going to find this
out?
Yeah.
What is the depth of this?
I don't want the answer.
Let me know the thought process.
The depth is nothing but from
root till that position.
I should come so from A to B,
from B to F from F2K that is
nothing but 1233 lines are
there, right?
So three is the depth of K cool.
So for any node, when we ask a
depth, we should traverse from
root to till that place and see
how many edges are there in
between them.
Well, perfect.
Now what about height?
Height of X again X can be any
node.
It is the number of edges in the
longest path from X to a leaf.
So in this case you should look
down South the moment I take a
note I should take or I should
enumerate all the paths to a
leaf.
Let's do this.
It might be a little complex for
newbies, so let's consider B.
I want to know what is the
height of.
So firstly, from B, what are all
the different ways to go to a
leaf? Yeah.
Yeah, no.
Firstly, tell me how many leaves
are there from B?
Is there?
Is there Jay?
Is there K is there right?
So I can go to all of them,
enumerate them, go from B to E
that is one possible way.
Or I can go from B to F and if I
go to if I can go to I.
Similarly, I can go from B to F
and from FI can go to J or I can
go from B to F from FI can go to
K So what are we doing?
We considered that node from
that node we looked below it and
enumerated all the paths which
can take me to a list through
this.
After doing this, for each of
that path, see how many edges
are there in them for BYOE how
much?
There's only one right, whereas
from B to F2I.
How many are there?
B2F is 1F2 is one more so it is
2.
What about B2F2J?
That is also 2V2F2K that is also
two, now a player Max function.
Alright, Max of 1/2 comma, 2
comma two is 2, so two is the
height of B.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys?
This is the most you know,
effective and correct way to do
it right.
What if X itself is a leaf?
What will be the height of it?
Can you guess it?
You will look down.
You will not be able to go to
any other relief, so it is 0.
So can I then give a new
definition?
Cleaning the definition which is
height of a node.
If it is 0, can I call it as a
leaf? Yes.
Right.
Cool.
Similarly, you can do it for a
also right for a you will
enumerate all the leaves and you
will get the answer as three
right?
What about a sub tree?
Right Sub tree is nothing but a
tree consisting of a node and
its descendants.
So if I carve out some portions
of it, something like this,
right?
So whatever is in this triangle,
I can call that to be a sub tree
of my original tree.
Hate to see GH.
They're a part of marginal tree.
If we just carve out that
portion, I can call it as this
is a sub tree of my.
Originally I can carve out any
portion, right?
I can carve out this F along
with his children, be along with
its children, and so on.
Level set of all nodes at the
same depth, right?
So always the root will start at
level 0, its children will be in
level one.
Then it's children will be in
level 2.
It children will be in Level 3
and so on, right?
So is level and dip then the
same.
Is it so?
Yes.
No.
Maybe F is in level 2 and what
is the depth of F? Yeah.
Level is nothing but always the
root.
Is at level zero.
Yeah, it's children are in level
one.
It's grandchildren are in level
2 and so on.
You have to just number it
always starting from root should
be 0.
So if you put that then if you
calculate are you getting the
level and depth as the same?
You guys will tell me what is
the depth of C that actually
from me you are coming right.
So depth of C is 1 level of it
is also one right for K.
The depth is what 123 it's level
is also three, right?
So can I comment that you know
depth 10 level are the same?
Yeah.
OK, Forest Forest is nothing but
a set of disjoint trees, right?
For example, I have this whole
tree.
Now I have another tree here
right for example, I have
another tree XY.
Z Now both the trees in this
slide together is called as a
forest.
Right.
So far so good, yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe.
So if they have multiple trees
which are disconnected, then I
can call them to be a forest.
A real life forest.
Krishna, right?
You have multiple trees.
That doesn't mean all trees are
related, right?
So what is the forest?
A forest is a collection of
trees.
There's also same thing in my
slide.
I have this one tree.
I have another tree here, so put
together they are called as a
forest, meaning they are
disjoint trees.
They're not connected, right?
I'm not connecting this A to
their or somewhere right?
Cool and gain some more
examples.
It is the same thing.
Length of a path is nothing but
the number of edges, right?
I'll give you some small
example.
You will tell me what is the
length XY?
That what is the length of this?
Yeah, learn this tool.
Very good.
I have another 1B QRS.
What is element?
Yeah, three, right, that is
nothing but the dashes.
This is 1.
This is 2.
This is 3 that is nothing but
the depth and height already.
We have seen right again depth
is nothing, but you'll have to
go from root till that yen
right?
So for a what will be the depth
then?
Yeah, death will be 0, right?
Because that itself is the root.
But what about B or BC&D?
The depth will be one because
from root I'm coming there.
That is just one, whereas for
E&F the depth will be 2
right from A to C&C to EC2FO
depth is 2, but depth you
understood?
But what about height?
Height on the other end is
reverse from that node.
I should see below and I should
enumerate all the paths to leave
and take the maximum right?
No, length is not depth.
Length is a general concept.
Yeah, length is nothing but how
many edges are there?
That's all right.
What about the height of P?
The height of C is what?
Yeah, for height of EN FR0 we
know that because they are leave
height of D is also zero because
it's a leaf, B is also zero,
whereas for C it has, you know
children and both of them are
yielding the same thing.
So these height is 1.
What about a height for a?
You will enumerate SA to BA to
DA, to CEA to CF.
This is yielding you 2, so
height of ACE 2.
Perfect.
So we learned these three.
What about the depth of the tree
itself?
If someone asks you not just a
node, if the whole tree is
asked, then it is the depth of
the deepest node.
So you should calculate the
depth of all the nodes and the
largest one, which you will get.
That will be the answer, yeah.
Again, yeah.
Amit and others got confused.
Yeah.
Please focus.
Yeah, we are repeating this
again and again height of a
notice, you'll have to look
down.
Yeah, you have to look down and
enumerate all the paths.
For example, if I want to know
what is the height of C from
sea, what are all the options to
go to a leaf.
I can go from C to EI can go
from C to F and in this how what
is the length of this?
And it will tell me that.
Yeah.
Real quick, Amit.
Three to EC2.
If it is just one, yeah, it is
not.
Two right is just one line,
right?
So that is the height of see.
Right.
What about a for?
Also, you should enumerate all
of them, right?
Enumerate meaning list out all
the possibility to go from A to
a leaf.
I can go from A to B that is
also valid.
I can go from A to D or I can go
from A to C to E or I can go
from A to C to F for this the
length is 1.
This is 1.
This is 2 this is 2 and what is
the Max, Max is 2 so hight of
ACE 2.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah.
Yeah, height and depth are not
the same, Vijay.
Yeah. So please don't interpret.
You know, they are not the same.
So for this example, right, if
you see for D right, the depth
is 1 whereas the height is 0,
right?
How are they the same?
For a the depth is 0 whereas the
height is 2, right?
How is tight end depth the same?
Yeah.
So what is the depth of a tree
here?
The depth of a tree is the depth
of the deepest node and height
of a trees.
Height of the root, so you
should calculate for the height
of the root and that's pretty
much right.
Pull.
So far, so good.
Hall of you.
As the definitions clear.
Right.
Pull.
So there are a lot of
interpretations that you can do.
I will leave it up to you to do
this.
Yeah.
So hight is downward correct,
yeah.
Is there a situation where
length and depth will be
different?
So what do you mean by length?
Your length is not a
terminology.
Entree length is nothing but the
number of edges.
That's all right.
So the actual terminology is
either height or depth or level.
There is nothing called as
length of a tree and something
like that, yeah.
Cool, now that you all told yes,
let's put it into practice.
Yeah, all of you here.
Yeah.
You can keep your
interpretations for the quiz.
Yeah, right there can be a lot
of interpretations that can be
done is the height of this node
same as, you know, depth of this
and you know degree and all
that, but let's not go into all
those derivations because that
is where the whole fun is right.
If I put all of them out here,
then there is no joy in you
drawing some trees and you know
concluding things right.
But all of you ready for this
activity?
Yeah, I'll keep asking questions
one by one.
Yeah.
And you will be answering things
the moment I get the correct
answers, I will go on to the
next question.
Right.
If you have, it is more like
that.
You know fastest fingers first.
If you already got the answers
then I will move on to the next
question.
Don't keep putting the previous
answers.
Yeah.
Are you game?
All of you?
Yeah, I still see some answers,
VISHAL and others.
Yeah, all all here.
Yeah.
There you go.
The very first question what
does the root here?
Yeah.
Yeah, very good.
That's right.
Yeah, you can stop now.
Yeah, the moment someone has
given the right answer, that's
it.
Yeah.
So either route here.
What are some internal nodes
name all the internal nodes in
one answer?
Yeah, you will not put one by
one in your single answer.
You will put all the internal
nodes in this particular tree.
Yeah.
Even though I have not seen an
answer.
Yeah.
Not even now, yeah.
So what is an internal node?
An internal node is someone who
has a child, right?
I see Soumya putting BCD.
That is not the correct answer.
BCDEF not the correct answer.
Yeah, Cambodia has told ABC
DE&H.
Yeah.
Which is correct? Yeah.
So let's take a minute and
retrospect.
It is a an internal node or not.
Well, then they need a lot of
people are making that same
mistake.
Yeah, simple stuff is A and
internal node or not, yeah.
Yeah, is also an internal node,
right?
Because A also has children, but
it is a special guy.
He's a root, but that is fine.
But going by their definition, A
also has children.
So A is also an internal node,
so A/B also has children.
C also has children.
D also has children.
E also has children.
Has also has children, so
ABCDE&H.
Right.
These are all your internal
notes.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
Well, if you who made a mistake?
Yeah.
Is this clear now?
Yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Cool.
Leaves.
Yeah, we'll put leaves real
quick.
Yeah, leaves are nodes which do
not have a children, right?
What all the leaves here go
systematically, yeah.
Yeah, real quick.
I still don't see the right
answer yet.
Yeah.
K LFG, M IJ.
Right, that's correct.
Perfect.
So all these guys, K, LFG, M,
all of them who do not have
children.
What are the ancestors of Yum?
Yeah.
What are the ancestors of M?
Yeah, I still don't see the
answer.
Yeah.
Ancestors of M, right?
Nope.
I still don't see the answers.
Still, I only see the previous
answers HD a that's the answer
right for M you'll go all the
way, which is H DNA.
Yeah.
There's no I don't see any
answers even now.
Yeah.
So all of you who are already
done, can you just stop the
previous answers?
Yeah, I still see only previous
answers flowing in.
Yeah, ancestors of M is already
done.
It is HDA.
What about descendants of E?
Yeah, real quick descendants of.
Yeah, real quick.
Descendance of ER KANSAL.
Alright, what does it degree of
a?
Yeah, teams is going to explode
today.
Yeah.
Again, maybe you can like others
answers if it is the same thing,
yeah.
What is the degree of a?
Well, I still see only you know
HDA.
Yes, yes, there is a lag.
Yeah, there's a huge lag here.
OK, let it settle down.
Let it settle down, yeah.
Yeah.
OK, is right after Kyle.
What is the next question degree
of a?
Yeah, let's give it another
minute.
I think it should, you know,
subside the whole lag and then
you know that's fine, that's
fine.
You can stop, you know, typing
and then the lag will be fine,
yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm at.
Got it. Yeah.
Zero.
Yeah, zero is absolutely wrong.
Many people have even zero.
He has a degree of three, right?
It has three children, BC&D,
so it is 3.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you.
Are you done?
Yeah.
Can you just stop typing now?
Yeah.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you are you done with
answering?
Yeah.
Can you stop typing now? Yeah.
Yeah, let the chat subside.
No, that will create even more
chaos, Vinay. Yeah.
But yeah, so far so good.
All of you.
Is it done? Yeah.
Degree of A is nothing but three
because we have three children.
There is BC&D so that is 3
right?
Cool.
So let's let's actually, you
know, stop here from the next
one.
I will give you the answers,
yeah.
Yeah, Arthi technology is clear,
yeah.
Right now, it's fine, right?
Yeah, there's no more lag.
Yeah.
Can you all stop typing?
Yeah, the answer is we already
got the correct answers for all
of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it'll stop now.
Yeah.
So I have not showing the next
question right.
So anyway, they will stop now.
The degree of A is nothing but
the number of children, so it is
a.
It is C, it is D, right?
As children are nothing but
BCSD, so it is nothing but
three.
Cool.
So far so good, guys, all of
you.
Can you just give thumbs up?
Yeah, instead of again typing.
Yes. Yes, yes.
Yeah.
So we actually had another
platform and I really, really
missed that platform.
Yeah.
So it can handle seamlessly more
than 1000 people.
Yeah, the chats and all this.
And we actually had to, you
know, forgo this platform.
And we came to teams and, you
know, the reality of teams now.
Yeah.
Cool SO3 is the correct answer
for a right.
So basically BCDR the children
so that is your number of
children, which is the degree of
a right.
So similarly, the degree of
hedge could be just one, right,
because it has just one child.
So on the next option, I'll only
give the answers, so the height
of the tree.
So for height of a tree, what we
should do, we should take the
height of a.
We should enumerate all the
paths to leave and we should
calculate the maximum right?
And what about I is in which
level, right?
So root is always in level 0.
It's children are in level one.
It's children are in level 2, so
I is in level 2.
What about depth of HHI can
always do like this H2D and D2A
so it is 2 or I can bring in
another analogy where I can tell
that I NHR siblings and I has a
level of two.
So H also has a level of two and
level and depth are same.
So H is a depth two.
I can give that definition or
that you know way of answering.
Also height of D so for DI
should you know look below.
So for DI, have you know 1/2?
I have one.
I have one so maximum is 2.
So eight of these two.
Cool.
So far so good, guys, all of
you.
Yes.
No.
Maybe is this clear so far?
Yeah, we'll take a small break
now.
Yeah, not more than 5 minutes.
We'll come back after the break,
but terminology is is it clear
for everyone?
Yeah, I'll keep asking in the
next few classes also here and
there, right.
Last two questions, depth and
height.
We already learned this several
times, yeah.
You know you can try to answer
it in the break.
Depth of edges depth is always
from root to that node, so A to
D and D2H that is 2, whereas
height of D is below.
So D2 is 1D2J is 1D2H2 Ms two.
So this is also two.
This is also to.
Depth and level are same,
correct?
Cool.
Let's take a short break.
940 will come back.
Yeah, I'll still be around if
you have some queries or
something else.
I use in level 2.
Yes, that's correct.
A is at level 0.
All is children are in level
one.
It's still run, are in level 2.
Yeah, this is the terminology
slide.
Ah, that's fine rishab as long
as you understood you can
always, you know, like the
answers.
Try to solve it, yeah.
There is nothing called limp.
That is what I'm again and again
repeating length is nothing but
a general English word.
Yeah.
Which means how many edges are
there?
That's all in a terminology
aspect.
For a tree, there is no length,
there is only depth.
There is height, there is
degree, there is level, there is
nothing called lymph.
Yeah, we can say a lot of
things.
I don't want to commend them.
Yeah.
So it's up to you to now, you
know, take this definitions
forward and you know, correlate
them, try to see what the same,
what is not same and you know
things like that. Yeah.
Because there are a lot of
interesting things around 3 in
your quizzes, I don't want to
spoil the, you know, fun by
giving out answers now.
And there was some question on
can we say internal node of a
same as.
So you're completely messing it
up so internal node means it is
a node which has children.
That's it.
Degree means how many children?
So how can you say both are same
right?
Internal node is basically a
true or false.
Sensor is a an internal node or
not.
You will say true or false,
whereas degree is always a
number.
Yeah, it is either zero or one
or two, or how many children are
there.
So those two cannot be the same,
right?
You actually move back, Krishna.
You wanted this slide?
Yeah, we are on a break.
We'll resume in another.
2-3 minutes.
By the way, what is the height
of this tree?
Cohen told four a couple of them
are also giving thumbs up.
Is it really 4 here?
No, it is 3.
Yeah.
Our mind is so deceiving.
You know, you you feel this is
one.
You are counting this as two.
You are counting this as three
and you're counting this as
four.
Yeah, but that's not right.
Actually this is the same line
here.
This is 1.
This is 2.
This is 3.
This will also help you 3 this
will help you 2.
This will lead you 1/2.
This will give you 123.
This will really two this will
you two maximum of it is 3 so
height of the tree is 3.
Cool.
Let's give it another minute for
others to join.
So far so good.
All of you.
What is a tree?
It's motivation.
How are they related?
The parent child and about the
various terminologies, number of
sub trees in this problem is 3
correct?
Yeah, the T1T2T3 that I have
marked, right, correct.
They are subtrees which I have
created.
You could have carved out
anything else.
Also, you can just take that EKL
that also you can take out you
can put it as T4 however you
want you can you know it's just
a sub part of your original
tree.
I thought D is 2.
Yes, that's correct.
All of you, is it clear guys?
Pre terminologies.
You can give a thumbs up as a
reaction.
Without a T1T2T3 form forest.
Yeah, exactly correct.
So if A is not there, then they
all become disjoint, right?
So they all become like 3
different trees.
They're not connected, so you
can call them as a forest.
Yeah, we can consider you K also
we can consider as I told it is
not exhaustive.
You can carve out any portions
of it.
Cool guys, it's 940, so let's
get started.
Yeah.
So some tree methods.
So what are the main methods of
a stack real quick?
What is the heart of a stack?
What operations can you do on
them?
Yeah, push and pop.
Very good.
What about a queue?
In a queue, what can I do?
I can do NQR.
Thank you.
Right.
Similarly, in a linked list, we
saw a lot of things that we can
do and in three what all can we
do?
I have two types, one is called
generic methods, one is called
accessor methods, right?
Or just to access them so
generic methods I can have the
size which will return the
number of nodes in the tree.
I can ask it's empty if the
whole tree is empty.
I don't have anything in the
tree right then.
It is is empty.
Is true, right?
Give me an answer as Boolean.
This will give me an answer as
integer right?
The number of nodes.
Or I can ask the elements where
it will return an iterator of
all the elements stored at nodes
of the tree.
Meaning iterator, it will return
right, meaning it will give me a
pointer via which I can iterate
all the nodes more like a loop,
right?
I'll be able to get all the
elements.
Whereas I can also have a
position, I can ask, you know,
return the root of the tree.
I can pass some node P and ask
return the parent of this node P
right?
But if I pause that P as my root
itself, then the root will not
have a parent, right?
So it will end up in an error.
Similarly, I can, you know, give
a P and ask give me all its
children. Right.
So all these type of methods I
can have, I can have query
methods, meaning I can give a
particular node and ask is this
an internal node, right test
whether node V is internal or
not, right?
Similarly, I can have is leaf or
is external where I will pass
that node V and ask is this
external node or not they how
will you find out if it's degree
zero?
Meaning, if it doesn't have any
children, or if it doesn't have
any descendants, it means it's
an external node.
Otherwise it's an internal node
is root, yeah.
How will you know if something
is a root or not?
It will not have a parent right
then that node is a root update
methods.
You can have you know V and WS2
nodes swap the elements stored
at the nodes V&W.
You can swap them or you can
replace the node V with E right.
You can replace them right?
So all these type of methods you
can do.
Yeah.
Will you be able to implement
all of these?
And then?
He asked.
Arthur built-in function.
Can I use this so in a couple of
languages these are built in,
but in a language like say see
or C++ they might not be built
in.
If you want to implement their
own tree, then you will have to
implement all these functions or
methods also right in Python
there are advanced libraries, so
you will be able to import them
in use it.
But knowing me, you know what is
to be done in your assignments?
You will not use any built-in
functions.
Yeah.
So there will be a rubric for
two marks.
If you have used built-in
functions, those two marks will
be one, right?
Because the point here is to
understand how a tree works
internally, right?
So how can you calculate if
something is external node or
not?
How can you know if something is
internal node or not, so that is
the point if you just use a
built in function, it is just
going to give you a true or
false where there is no meaning
then so in all your assignments
you will not be using built-in
functions although they are
available, right?
Cool.
So far so good.
All of you, we will just try to
learn sudo codes.
One for depth and one for height
right?
And then we'll proceed ahead.
So depth.
Yeah, all of you are here.
I don't see any replies, so I'm
a little confused.
Yeah.
Is everyone back?
Did you get all the methods?
I can have query methods update
methods or you know accessing
methods and all those.
Right.
Cool.
It's a good practice for you,
you know, try to do them, you
know, in scratch using Python.
Let's go back to these two my
thirds depth and height.
I want to calculate it.
Let V be a node of a treaty.
Yeah, we some node inside a
tree.
I want to know that node V's the
death of V is the number of
ancestors of V excluding V
itself.
Itself you definition right.
Previously we saw depth test.
Something else, right?
We told from the root.
I'll come till here.
That end, this definitions are
the same only, but it has been
rephrased in a manner that you
know you can convert this into
programming.
I'll repeat what I've just told.
The depth of V is the number of
ancestors of V excluding V
itself.
Let's put it into practice.
Let's take an example for this
particular node.
Consider this node right.
I want to calculate its dip.
Right.
The number of ancestors of it,
excluding him, right?
So what can I tell about this?
And sister Susan ancestor, this
is an and sister.
This is an ancestor SO3
ancestors are there, so that is
nothing but it's def.
Yes.
No, maybe that is what we are
doing here.
So that again, how do I
calculate right?
I know that if V is the root,
then the depth of V0 correct?
How I can calculate this now you
will see the magic for this
node.
I want to calculate, so I will
say that depth of this is one
place, the depth of its parent.
So what is the depth of its
parent?
I don't know that is again the
one plus the depth of its
parent.
What about his one plus the
depth of his parent?
Right.
And what about the depth of the
parent?
This is 0 correct because this
is the root, so this zero will
come here.
So 1 + 0 is 1.
This one will come here 1 + 1 is
2.
This two will come here.
2 + 1 is 3 and sister by default
doesn't include V right?
Why are we exclusively?
Yeah.
Just just to make it clear.
Yeah, it doesn't include by
definition, just to make it
clear for you, I have explicitly
told that don't count them. Also
right?
Is it clear?
If if we use the root, then the
depth of V0.
So now why is this line given?
Yeah, in your actual code, where
will this be used?
Let's see.
Someone is able to get that.
Yeah, in your recursion.
Exactly.
Yeah, common is bang on.
That is your base case, right?
Your base case is nothing, but
when you hit the root, the root
will have a 0, right?
So that is your base case.
So if you see the algorithm,
otherwise the depth of VS1 plus
the depth of the parent.
So if you see the code here,
depth three is the TV is the
node I want to find out if T dot
is root of V, meaning in the
tree I'm asking is this V the
root?
If so, then return it as zero.
That is the base case.
Otherwise return one plus depth,
meaning the same word is being
used.
So recursion you pass the same
key there is instead of V you
are passing it's parent is root
of V where is the.
I'll go for this.
Yeah, that is what we told here
that you will be able to write.
It is root of V.
Yeah, he's root of how will you
check someone who doesn't have a
parent is the root.
So you'll have to write this,
you know definitions.
But as I told in Python there
are already functions to do all
this.
Yeah, so far, so good.
This algorithm did all of you
get it?
We'll keep doing one plus the
depth of parent one plus the
depth of parent.
You will hit the root at some
stage where the root will give
you 0 and then you will be able
to get the answer.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can use it.
Yeah, no problem in your
assignment alone, you cannot use
in other places.
You can use it.
Cool.
So what is the worst case? Yeah.
Oops.
During time of the algorithm is
depth of T comma, V is 1 + d of
1 plus.
Yeah, we were D of V denotes the
depth of the node way in the
tree.
In the worst case, the depth
algorithm runs in Bitcoin time,
where N is the total number of
nodes in the tree.
Why is it so?
Yeah, T dot parent is also a
method, correct?
Yeah.
Why is this guy?
So this last line, why is this
happening?
We are telling we go of yen.
Why is it so?
Can I have a tree like this?
Yeah.
Something like this.
So in this case, if I ask this
nodes depth, is it not
traversing all of them and then
you know giving me the answer as
you know, the number of nodes.
Exactly right.
By the way, this is a very
powerful concept.
This is called a skewed tree.
While the squirrel tree we'll
come back to him later.
Yeah, but because of him running
time is again we go off and cool
depth algorithm.
You understood.
What about the height?
So for height the height of a
treaty is equal to the maximum
depth of an external node.
Again, another new definition.
Can you explain the last two
points which last two points?
Yeah.
So forget about this point.
This is what is the correct
answer.
The worst case of you know
calculating the depth is we go
of yen.
Why is that?
Because of this type of a tree,
if I draw a tree like this, this
is also a tree.
If I want to calculate the depth
of this last node here, I should
come all the way from the root
till this and I would have
touched all the nodes right?
That is why complexities big O
of N.
Full height of a tree, right?
Yeah, that is something
different.
That is one place.
This part is going to take
another time, right?
So and this part we are telling
that is a deep this is more like
an average case which we don't
want.
Yeah, forget about it.
This is always the correct
answer because I can always draw
a tree like this and prove that
it is big of north.
Yeah.
And yeah, as I told, we will not
go into best case, average case
and all that.
Yeah, big of north is the
correct answer here.
Yeah, forget about this.
Also, because I can always draw
tree like this.
Yeah.
For root running time will be 0,
right?
So what do you mean by that?
If you have only one root.
And by the way, running time is
not zero for any algorithm.
Yeah, it will definitely take
some constant.
You cannot tell it as zero.
Well, so the height of a tree is
equal to the maximum depth of an
external node.
Yeah.
Again, a new definition.
We are coming up right maximum
depth of an external node,
right?
Let's again, you know, go back
here.
So the height of all the leaves
are zero.
Bricked the height of this one
is one child for this it is
going to be this one because
there are two children.
Both of them are in the same,
you know they don't have any sub
children, so it is one for this
one.
It is 2 because it is one, then
again 2.
For this node, we'll have to
enumerate all of them and then
try to take the maximum right.
But if you observe this
carefully, is the height of this
route same as the depth of the
deepest node?
Yeah, the depth of this whole
tree is 3 and that is nothing
but the height of the root or
the height of the tree, right?
There's some observations that
you need to keep doing, but now
let's look at this.
The height of a treaty is equal
to the maximum depth of an
external node, right?
That is what we just saw.
If we as an external node then
the height of V0, right?
We know that for all the leaves,
the height is 0 because it
doesn't have any children.
Then what is the question of
height?
Otherwise the height of V is 1
plus the maximum height of the
child, right?
Otherwise, if it is not a leaf,
if it is an internal node then
it is maximum of the child's you
know number of children.
Children.
So how will you write the
algorithm if T dot is 6, is
external or is leaf, then return
0, because for external nodes
the height is 0, otherwise have
it as zero, like a variable for
each W belonging to T dot
children.
So manually, how did we do it?
You remember right, we had to
enumerate them.
We will enumerate from A to BB
to E2F that is one path and then
from B2C E to E that is the 2nd
path like that we need to
enumerate so that is why we are
doing for each for each of the
children that it has.
Try to calculate that maximum
right Max function.
We are using maximum of existing
H that is why we initialize to
00 comma.
Again, we are putting height
which is nothing but a
recursion.
Finally, you will add one to it,
right?
If you want to calculate the
whole height of a tree instead
of this V you can pass T dot
root itself.
If you pass the root itself to
this algorithm, you will get the
height of the whole tree right
again for this also the
complexity is big off yen.
Yeah.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
If it is a leaf given to you
directly, give it a 0.
Otherwise, do one plus the
maximum height of all its
children.
You'll have to enumerate them
and calculate the number of
children and their heights.
Yeah, so far, so good, all of
you.
Yeah.
So the worst case we we go of
yen for both the algorithms
depth and height.
So more about it in your, you
know text.
I've also given you some, you
know chapter names here, right?
So you can also have a look at
this.
Yeah, but I also give you a
simple example of a skewed tree,
right.
If you have a tree like this,
then if you want to calculate
depth or height, you might have
to touch all the nodes and
because of that it will become
we go off.
Yeah.
So far so good, guys, all of
you.
Can you proceed ahead?
Yeah.
So it's pretty straightforward.
I'll again and again repeat.
Please practice these.
Trace them.
Yeah.
In the class, we may not be able
to trace like you know every
line.
Yeah.
So it's if it's an external
node, the height is 0, otherwise
this simple block of code is
again using recursion where we
are trying to enumerate them
right for all its children,
right for each W belonging to
their children, catch hold of it
and try to take the maximum
height of it right, which is
exactly what we did manually.
Also right.
For example, if I want to
calculate the height of this
node right, I should be doing
this path I should be
calculating for this path I
should be calculating for this
path.
Then I should take the maximum
amount of it, which is what we
are doing here.
What each of its children try to
calculate it the height and use
the mask Max function, yeah.
Actually proceed it, guys, all
of you.
Yeah, it's an open book exam.
Of course you know you can refer
these if at all it is needed,
yeah.
Is exactly what we did manually,
right?
We have to enumerate all of that
path, that is, for each children
W right for each W belonging to
this children, right?
This is one child, this one
child again, children and so on.
Right.
And since we start from the, you
know, base, we'll have to do it
as one plus.
Otherwise, you'll get one lesser
right, this one.
Also, we should account right
this one, otherwise you will
just be counting these further
children's and you will get one
height lesser, right?
Cool so far.
Have we put any constraints on
the tree panda tree?
Have you know ten children?
Is it possible?
Yeah.
Is it possible or not here?
Yeah.
In this, A has three children,
right?
All that is possible, but now we
will start putting a lot of
constraints and they are called
different different types of
trees.
I want to discard all those,
come back fresh.
Yeah.
And we will keep putting them
names very, very important.
They are all very related.
Yeah, I want all of you to
focus.
Yeah, just another few minutes,
then I'll leave you free for the
day.
But they are very important.
Yeah, firstly binary tree.
A binary tree is a tree with the
following properties.
Each internal node has at most
two children.
The children of the node are
called as left child and right
child.
So what does this mean at most?
Meaning maximum?
Yeah, at most you can get 100
marks.
Something like that, right in a
binary tree, each internal node
can have at most two children,
meaning it can have one child,
or it can have two child.
It cannot be more than two.
Great.
So if you consider this
particular tree is a leaf,
there's a leaf no problem.
This is an internal node.
It has one child.
This is an internal node.
It has two children.
This is an internal node.
It has two children.
Internal node has one child.
Internal node has two children,
so this is a binary tree.
Yeah.
Is it making sense days?
All of you for every internal
node it can have maximum two
children, not more than that.
This is also a binary tree
because this has only one node,
right?
So this is this is acting like a
leaf.
It doesn't have any child, so
this is also a binary tree.
What about this?
Can someone tell me if this is a
binary tree or not?
This is an internal node.
It has two children.
This is an internal node.
It has one child.
This is an internal node.
It has one child, so this is
also a binary tree.
Perfect, all of you.
Binary trees.
It clear all internal nodes if
they have maximum two children
then it is a binary tree.
Now there is another one.
It is called as a strict or a
proper or a full binary tree.
Yeah, all three are the same.
I will prefer to call it as a
proper binary tree.
Yeah, you can prefer to call it
in other ways.
Also, a proper binary tree is.
Each internal node has exactly
two children, right?
Exactly two children it has to
have something like this.
This is an internal node.
It has exactly two children.
This is an internal node.
It has exactly two children,
those an internal node.
It has exactly two children.
These are all leads, so this is
a proper binary tree.
Yeah, each node can have either
two or zero children.
If it is having two then it
means it is internal node.
If it is having zero, it means
it is a leaf.
Complete binary tree?
Yeah.
Is is this clear case all of you
proper binary tree binary tree
means maximum two children.
It can have one child also,
whereas in proper binary tree it
has to have exactly two children
or no children at all.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you will slowly.
It will get complicated.
Yeah, these two trees are.
Is it clear?
Yeah, I don't see any responses
real quick and you react.
Yeah, I only see Aditi.
Others.
Yeah, full complete binary tree.
Very, very important.
Many other concepts will use
this, so please focus here,
yeah.
Complete binary tree is nothing
but a binary tree in which first
of all it's a binary tree,
right?
Meaning it cannot have three
children and so one maximum only
two.
It can have a binary tree in
which every level except the
lowermost is completely filled
right at the lowermost level.
Loads must be filled from left
to right.
Yeah, let's look at this.
This is level 0 level one, level
2, Level 3 right level 0 level
one, level 2 level 3IN level 0
maximum.
How many nodes you can have?
Yeah, at level 0, can I have
two?
No, I can have only the root.
Only one node can be there,
right?
Or in other terms, I can say two
power level, meaning two power
02 power 0 is what anything to
the power, zero is 1.
So I can have only one node that
one node is already here in
level one.
How many children can be there?
Yeah, since it is binary, right?
Two power 1/2 power level right
to two can be there.
So if there there is 2 here.
Completely there in level 2.
How many children can be there?
If no children, then also proper
yes.
Yeah, poop power 24 can be
there.
So all four are here meeting
here.
Also, two children can be there
for this board.
Both are there for this.
Node two can be there, both are
there for this whole, so two can
be there, both are there.
So this is still the last but
one level in the last level it
is filled from as left as
possible, meaning here there is
a left child.
There is a right child, then the
next child should be.
For this only I cannot draw it
for this one or this one.
Yeah, I'll have to draw for this
node also.
1st it's left child, then it's
right child, meaning at the
lowermost level the nodes must
be filled from left to right.
I'll have to start from here and
start filling here.
I can't randomly add somewhere
here, then it will not be a
complete binary tree.
Is this clear for all of you?
Maximum nodes at a level is 2
power I.
What are the difference between
complete binary and proper?
That's exactly what we are
looking at in a proper binary
tree, all the nodes will have
exactly two children or no
children at all.
But here I can always have
something like I'll write and
show you for you.
Is this now a complete binary
tree?
Yeah, it is still a complete
binary tree because still this
level 2, all of them are fully
filled and at the last level it
is filled from left to right.
Whereas is this a proper binary
tree?
Publish.
Is this a proper binary tree?
No, because this should have
also had two, otherwise it is
not a proper right.
So now we've got the difference.
This one.
Is it a complete binary tree or
not?
The moment you look at it, you
should be replying. Yeah.
No, it is not a complete binary.
Because of this guy.
L0L1L2 all of them are
completely filled no problem,
but in L3 it is violating.
It is not as left as possible.
What about this guy?
This should have had the
children, right, but it is not
there, so this is not a complete
binary tree.
OK, no problem.
Now we agree this is not a
complete binary tree, but is
this a proper binary tree?
Proper binary tree, meaning all
nodes should have internal nodes
should have exactly 2 internal
node.
It has exactly 2 internal node,
exactly 2 internal node, exactly
2 internal node, exactly 2.
So this is a proper binary tree,
but not a complete binary tree.
Yeah, all good.
Yes.
No.
Maybe I'll Draw Something for
you.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Keep answering me real quick.
Yeah.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yes.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yes.
Now also it is a complete binary
tree because this level this
level is fully filled.
Here I'm feeling from left to
right.
So which is the only position
where I can put the next node to
still maintain it as a complete
binary tree?
I'll have to put it here now.
If I put something here now, it
is not a complete territory,
right?
Because here it is missing.
Cool.
Now you got it.
Now we have something called as
perfect binary tree, right?
What is this?
A perfect binary tree is a type
of binary tree in which every
internal node is exactly two
child nodes.
So till here in the definition,
if you see what does it reflect
still here in the definition?
What is that called?
By any trees are in which every
node has exactly 2.
It is proper right and and all
the leaf nodes are at the same
level.
Two conditions, right?
If it is having exactly two
children and all the leaves are
at the same level, then it is a
perfect binary tree.
In this case, internal has two
children.
Internal has 22.
All these leaf nodes are in the
same level then it is.
Perfect. Right?
Let me also clarify this to you.
But this particular tree that I
have drawn is this a proper
binary tree?
Internal node.
It has two children.
This internal node has two
children, right?
So this is a proper binary tree,
but is it a perfect binary tree?
No.
Why with us?
This is L0 level 0.
This is level one.
This is level 2 and you will
observe that these two leaf
nodes are in level 2, whereas
this particular leaf node is in
level one, so that is not
allowed in perfect.
Right, but this is completely
agreed.
This is a proper binary tree
because each internal node has
exactly two children.
Yeah.
Now I have another question, is
this a complete binary tree CBT?
Yeah.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yes, because here it is fully
filled.
Here it is fully filled.
Here it is filled from left to
right.
Is a clear case all of you.
So can I put some lines like all
perfect binary trees are proper
binary trees?
Is that correct?
All perfect binary trees are
proper binary trees.
All proper binary trees are not
perfect.
Binary trees.
Is that correct?
All perfect.
Are of proper, but all proper
may not be perfect well.
There are some small formulas
for you.
Yeah, I will urge you to, you
know, have a look at this.
This is there in particular in
your Corman textbook.
Yeah, there's nothing related to
your exams and all that.
But if you're interested, you
can have a look at these proofs,
meaning the maximum number of
nodes in a binary tree with high
tech.
Right, all perfect binary tree
are proper and complete tree.
Think about it, yeah.
Are perfect binary trees
complete binary trees also?
Is that the case?
Yes. No.
Yeah.
Yeah, Krishna says no.
So can you come with some
counter argument?
Can you Draw Something and show
why is it not?
Yeah, you can expect all these
type of questions, guys.
Yeah, unable to get the
difference between perfect and
complete binary tree so perfect.
Meaning all the leaves should
also be in the same level, so
this is a perfect one right?
The moment I add a new node
here, I add a new node here.
So is this perfect binary tree
now?
Apparati is this now a perfect
binary tree?
Akhil, answer yeah.
Because all these leaf nodes are
in some level, but this leaf
node alone, he's in some other
level, right?
So the moment you do this, this
is not a perfect binary tree,
whereas this is still a complete
binary tree then it is also not
complete by any tree.
No, it is a complete binary
tree, right?
It is definitely a complete
binary tree because till this
last but one level all are fully
filled in the last level you
have added a node from left to
right, so this is a complete
binary tree.
Right.
What is it?
A proper binary tree?
Yeah, it is not a proper binary.
Correct, because this internal
node does not have two children.
So in this example, this is only
a complete binary tree, right?
This is not a perfect binary
tree.
This is not a proper binary tree
also.
Yeah, fully filled, meaning
fully occupied.
So in the level 0 you can have
only one node.
It is already there in level
one.
You can have two power, one
which is 2 nodes.
Both are here in Level 3 it is 3
right Level 3 so it can have two
power.
Oops, this is 0.
This is 1.
This is 2.
This is level 2, so two power
two is 4, so four only can be
there.
So all four are here.
So it is we can call it as in
that level it is fully occupied.
It is not that this node is
missing or this node is missing.
Yeah.
Is it making sense for all of
you said why the first shown
complete binary is not a proper
binary tree?
Where this one you mean with
slight NANDINI?
Yeah, first example, this one
right.
This was my very first example,
yeah, so this one.
So each internal node.
So first of all, all of us agree
that this is a complete binary
tree.
Yes. No.
Yeah.
So that is why I was again going
slow.
But you know, so we can lot of
you have got confused.
Let me repeat it very clearly
one last time.
All of you, please focus. Yeah.
Let's go back.
Come from here.
Proper meaning only one rule
right?
Very simple.
Only one rule, Amit.
Yeah, all of you.
Please listen, don't ask the
same thing.
I'm repeating all the trees
again binary tree, meaning it
can have maximum two children,
right?
Is this a binary tree?
We'll stay focused.
We learn one by one.
Yeah.
Is this a binary tree?
Yes, it is a binary tree.
Why is it not a binary tree?
It is having only one child
binary treatments maximum.
It can have two it can have one.
Also, it can have two also
right?
So this is a binary tree.
Perfect.
Now let's come back to proper
proper meaning.
Each internal node has exactly
two children.
Is this a proper binary tree?
This is an internal node.
This has a child.
It has only one child, so it is
not a proper binary tree.
It has to have exactly 2.
Now it has become a proper
binary tree, right?
So if for every level, so if you
see here, this is an internal
node.
This has two this is an internal
node.
It has two this is an internal
node.
It has two, so this is called a
proper binary tree.
I draw one for here.
The moment I have done this now,
is it a proper binary tree?
Because this internal node has
only one child.
So now I have spoiled it.
He played the spoilsport.
Now this is not a proper binary
tree.
How can I make it a proper
binary tree?
I will add one more here.
So is this now a proper binary
tree?
ASMI nadas all of you now.
Is this a proper binary tree?
Yes.
So now is proper binary tree
clear for everyone?
Right.
Cool, now coming back to
complete binary tree complete
binary tree meaning.
Until the last but one level, it
should be fully filled.
What do I mean by fully filled
meaning in this level 0 maximum
I can have only one node.
That formula is given by two
power I where I stands for level
right?
SO2 Power 0 means two power zero
is equal to 1.
Only one node can be there, it
is already there and then in
level one I can have two power,
one which is 2.
I can have two nodes, both of
them are there and index level.
It is L2 so I can have two power
two which is 4 nodes.
All four are here, meaning it's
fully filled, right?
We up to its full capacity, it
is already filled and in the
last level it may not be fully
filled, but it should be from
left to right.
So in this case, is it from left
to right these two nodes they're
coming suddenly from this
particular node.
What about this guy?
He should have been here, right?
So now I cannot tell it this is
a complete binary.
This is not a complete binary
tree, whereas if I draw it here,
even if I put one now, this is a
complete binary tree.
But the moment I put only one,
is this now a proper binary
tree?
Because proper definition says
that every internal node should
have two exactly.
But here 2 is not there, but
still I'm OK.
This is a complete binary tree.
This is not a proper binary
tree, but if I add one more here
Now this becomes both complete
binary tree also and proper
binary tree also because till
this level all are fully filled
in the last level we are filling
it from left to right so it is
complete binary tree.
It is AC T and proper monetary
also.
Yes, because this internal node
has two children.
This has two children.
This has two children, so it is
proper.
Also, right now certainly I add
one node here.
Now you will comment about is it
a proper binary tree or not?
Is it a CBT or not?
Go ahead and tell me.
Don't jump the bridge, Amit.
We will come there for now.
We have just learned what is
binary, what is proper, what is
complete.
Yeah, there's also no.
There's also no correct because
here you are not filling it from
left to right.
What about this node?
What about this left node?
Suddenly you add it here so it
is not a CPT and here again this
internal node is not having two
children, it has only one.
So it is not a proper also, so
no one knows the correct answer
right?
So far so good, all of you.
Right I have added a node.
Here is the CBT right I've added
one more.
This is the CBT also and now
this is a proper binary tree
also.
Now let's go back to that last
day.
Who's perfect perfect is very
simple, right?
He just says all internal nodes
should have exactly two children
and and all the leaves should be
in the same level.
So in this case, if you see the
first part of the definition is
clear, all the internal nodes
have exactly two children.
These internal node has two
children.
This has two children.
This has two children, no
problem, but they are not in the
same level.
So if you see the leaves date,
these are all leaves which are
in which level real quick.
Yeah.
Which level L0L 1L2.
Whereas these two are also
leaves which are in L3.
If you have that case, then it
is not a perfect binary tree.
It is not a perfect binary tree,
but you can definitely tell that
it is A proper binary tree
because all the nodes have
exactly two children and it is
also a complete binary tree.
In this case, what all I can say
proper or not, CBT or not
perfect or not?
What will be your answers proper
is yes, CBT is yes perfect.
There's no.
Is it now clear for all of you?
Yeah.
Accurately, all of you, others,
all the definitions, right.
Yeah.
And they draw a tree, which is
all the three.
Is that possible?
Yeah.
Is that possible?
Can I draw a tree which satisfy
all the tree properties?
Yeah, definitely.
Yes, right.
If I Draw Something like this.
Is this binary?
Yes, nobody is having three
children, right?
So it is binary.
Is it proper?
Yes, all internal loads have
exactly two children.
Perfect.
Is it AC T?
Yes, all the nodes.
All the levels are fully filled
and is it perfect?
Also yes.
Cool.
Done right.
So now we will look at some
formulas, right?
So very simple formulas are
there.
That is, if I have a binary tree
with height hitch right, that
high is given to you, right?
I'm telling you that height
cannot go more than four.
No.
Can you tell me how many maximum
nodes can I fill there?
That is given by this formula
that is at the very first level.
How many nodes you can have?
You can have two power zero and
in level one you can have two
power one.
Then you can have two power two
and so on up to two power H
where H is the height right.
So now this is a mathematical
equation, so you can actually,
you know, rewrite it as two
power H + 1 -, 1, right where H
+ 1 is nothing but the number of
level. Right?
So I can just replace that and
tell that this this itself is
the answer actually to power H +
1 -, 1 that many number of nodes
you can fill right.
For example, if I have three as
the height, they have height is
equal to three.
How many maximum nodes I can
fill at the topmost?
I can just put one right and the
next level I can put two and
then in the next level I can put
another four right total.
How much is it?
Only seven, right?
Yes. No.
Do you also need to know, uh?
Threaded.
No, not at all.
Yeah, only these.
So these are just basic formulas
which is telling you how much
maximum number of nodes can be
there with height or the other
way around.
Also, if maximum number of nodes
are given, we can also find out
what will be its height, right?
Will he be able to put 10 nodes
in a tree with height 2?
Is that possible?
I have 10 nodes in hand.
Can I just put it in a tree with
height 2 not possible, right?
Because I can have only one in
the first level, I can only two,
then the others will go down
right?
Only four can be here, right?
So here I was not able to occupy
all 10 right?
So this formula gives you the
height needed.
So if we have 10 nodes, what is
the you know log 10 value floor
value?
Right, that'll be your answer of
how much height you will need in
order to fit your 10 nodes.
Right.
What is the min and Max height
of a binary tree, right?
If I want the minimum height, I
will start filling in all the
sites maximum possible right?
In this only one possible, I'll
put it in this I have I can put
two.
I have put two this I can put
four.
I'll put all the four so then
I'll get the minimum height, but
if I want maximum height then
I'll just put one one in each
level, right?
Then I'll have maximum if I want
to place 8 nodes then I'll have
high test seven.
I can put it like this, right?
This will give you the maximum
height, but the same 8 nodes.
If you want minimum height, I'll
fully occupy it like this.
Right.
Well, they're all simple, you
know, formulas and tricks.
Yeah, not much.
Balanced binary tree will come.
We will come to this later.
Don't.
Uh, you know, worry too much
about it.
There's a complete class on
this.
We will look at it at that time.
So, but it is something to do
with calculating some
differences and so on.
Who will come back at that time?
Forget it for now.
Yeah, but so far, so good.
All of you.
What is a binary tree?
What is a proper binary tree?
What is a complete binary tree?
What is a perfect binary tree
and some small definitions here
and there like formulas of, you
know, log north and so on?
It's an open book exam.
You can always, you know, refer
them, if at all you need.
Is it clear, guys, all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Now I have a question.
How do you implement a stack?
Yeah.
How do you implement a stack?
Yeah, real quick.
No, no, you need not memorize.
Yeah, there will not be
questions which will require you
to memorize, yeah.
You can actually derive all
this.
Uh, how I drew this you can
actually derive these also by
doing it, no push pop is wrong.
Akriti is right, you can use
either array or a linked list.
Similarly, what about queue?
You can use an array or a linked
list.
So similarly binary tree.
Also you can use either a linked
list or an array, yeah, but
there is a caveat here.
Whenever you have a complete
binary tree, right?
What is it?
Complete binary tree.
Then you will use an array
right.
In other cases you will use a
linked list.
Why is it so?
Because if you represent a
complete binary tree using an
array or for that matter, you
can also say perfect binary tree
if it is a complete binary tree
or if it is a perfect binary
tree, then you can actually have
a.
Party.
Otherwise you have to use a
linked list, right?
But First things first, how do
you represent Petrina Nari?
Right.
Let's look at that complete
binary trees can be represented
in memory with the use of an
array so that all nodes can be
accessed in.
We go off one time, root will be
in the first position.
Label the node sequentially from
top to bottom, left to right,
right?
If I have it so, what type of a
tree is this?
Can you comment about what type
of a tree this is?
Of course, firstly it is a
binary tree.
It is a complete binary tree,
correct?
The last level from left to
right, we are feeling it is a
complete binary tree.
How do you place it in an array?
Very simple guys.
Just put a label top to bottom,
left to right.
Yeah, this is not perfect.
Binary tree NANDINI.
Yeah.
Perfect binary tree?
No, it is wrong.
It is only a complete binary
tree because if you see here.
These leaves are here.
They are not in the same level,
right?
So it is not perfect.
It is only complete.
OK, now let's you know.
Try to see how to represent this
in an array.
Start numbering top to bottom,
left to right, meaning you put
it as 1234567891011.
Is the numbering clear for all
of you?
Yeah.
Is the numbering clear?
All of you.
Yeah, Vijay, that's right.
It is proper also.
Yeah, top to bottom, left to
right.
Just put it as 123456 top to
bottom, left to right.
You will number it after you
number it.
Whatever you numbered, right?
Very, very important.
Started from one don't start it
from zero.
Started from one and then in an
array.
Whatever you numbered those
numbers become the index.
Put the actual node value as the
content of the array and you are
done and now you have these
three formulas which will tell
you indexing should start.
No, in this case alone it should
not start from zero, because if
you start from zero, all these
three formulas will stop
working, so that zero position
can be empty.
You know that it is empty.
Always only from first position
you will put it.
You'll start from one.
You'll number it top to bottom,
left to right that then you will
use these formulas.
That is, for any node.
If you want to know who is the
left child, let's consider this
node 16 right?
Where is he?
He's positioned in the poor
place this place.
If I want to know who is the
left child, I will go to a of
two I and.
What is a of two?
I he of two into three that is a
of six.
I'll go to a of 6 and I have 15
so my formula says the left
child of this 16 is 15.
If you come to this tree, the
left child of 16 is 15, so my
formula is correct.
Similarly, if I want to know the
right child, I'll do 2I plus
one.
So I will go to a of seven and
that is 18.
So my formula says 18 is your
right child and in the diagram
also 18 is my right child.
And if I want to know who's the
parent of the 16 right, my
formula says parent of I is at
position floor I by two.
So my 16 is at position three,
so 3 / 2 floor value is 1.5
floor value which is 1.
So I'll go to one first
position.
First position is 14 so my
formula says 14 is the root or
parent of the 16.
So actually in diagram also 14
is my parent of 16.
So these formulas are working.
So if I represent it in a array
using these formulas, I'll be
able to know who's the left
child who's the right child
who's the parent.
Is this clear for all of you?
But if you start numbering it
from zero, it will be wrong.
Floor value is the floor, the
decimal part.
If you have 1.5 floor value, you
will take the answer as one that
is called floor value.
If it is seal, you will take the
higher number, meaning you will
take it as two.
Yeah.
Which part Prakash did you
understand the numbering part?
Yeah, numbering part.
Is it clear if numbering part is
clear then the formula just says
pick up any node.
If you want to know who is the
left child, use this formula.
That is, go to two i.e.
Position if you want to know for
that node who is the right
child, go to to a + 1 position
and if you want to know for that
node what is the parent, go to I
by two I is that node where you
are looking at.
I want to know I consider this
particular node.
I will become four.
So you want to know who is the
left child of it?
You will go to hate.
You want to know what is the
right child.
You go to 9.
You want to know its parent.
You'll do 4 / 2, which is 2.
There you will find its parent.
Here you will find its left.
Here you'll find it right.
Is it clear?
Please put these formulas into
action.
Yeah, take some node.
Take the I value and substitute
and see are you getting the
correct left child, right, child
and parent.
Yeah, so far, so good, all of
you.
Yes.
No, maybe I don't see any
replies at all.
Very simple guys.
Yeah.
Just, you know 3 formulas do I
will give you left child do I
plus one will give you right
child.
I / 2 floor value will give you
who's the parent of that node.
Yeah, always remember thought
from one.
If you start from zero then this
will become two into zero, might
become zero and all that.
So don't do that.
So if it is a complete binary
tree, then this representation
is good.
If it is a normal tree, not a
complete binary tree, then you
have a problem.
So in this example, let me just
finish this and then I'll leave
you free.
This tree is this a complete
binary tree?
Real quick.
This tree that you see here in
the slide is this a complete
binary tree?
No here itself, there is a
violation here itself.
There is no right child to this,
so in these cases what will
happen is if you try to
represent this in this array,
those positions this third
position will become an empty
again.
Here it's children.
All these positions will be
empty, so you are actually
wasting memory.
Right.
So that is why we are claiming
that if it is a complete binary
tree, then all of these will be
completely filled, right?
So you will have a array which
is like this.
It'll be fully filled, right?
So no problem.
Use an array, but if it is a
normal tree like this, which is
not a complete binary tree,
right?
In fact, is this even a proper
binary tree?
Yeah.
Is this a proper binary tree?
This is not a proper binary
tree.
Also, this is not a complete
binary tree.
Also, this is not a perfect
binary tree.
Also, this is a normal binary
tree, right?
In those cases, you should not
use an array because if you use
an array you will have a lot of
empty spaces in between, so you
are wasting space, so you should
not do that.
Then you should use the linked
list representation, right?
There's also a similar example
where these dotted ones are not
actually there, so all those
positions are becoming null
here.
So you are wasting space.
So if it is a CBT, you will use
a array.
In all other cases, you will use
a linked list representation.
We'll look at this in detail in
the next class, but just for you
to have a glimpse, it'll look
like this.
There'll be 4 compartments, one
will point to the parent, one
will point to the left child,
one will point to the right
child, one will point to the
actual value, right?
This is nothing but a linked
list, right?
We will stop here.
We will continue from here in
the next class.
We will go deep into this linked
list representation and then we
will come back to the next
concept of heap and other
things.
If it is a complete binary tree,
you will use an array.
You know, all other cases you
will use this type of a linked
list if you have already
understood list.
You understood this also right
this.
This is having four compartment
will have the actual value.
You will have the parent
pointer.
You will point to the left.
You will point to the right in
that way you will not waste any
space.
For the root element, the parent
will be empty.
I did because it doesn't have
any parent.
For leaves, the left child and
right child will be empty.
Null pointer right?
Was it doesn't have a left or
right child because it's a leaf.
Yeah, the actual value is the
actual value, right?
It can be a number or it can be
an integer or whatever we have
inside these nodes, right?
This CB these become the actual
value.
Right.
Is it clear, guys, all of you,
what is we use link list for
everything.
Yeah, you can use that also.
Yeah, but for a complete
manager, you don't need all that
complexity.
You can just put it in an array
and that'll work, but you can
use linked list also to not be a
problem.
Yeah, but you have all this
unwanted, you know.
Uh, the complexity is not big of
one you have, you know, extra
memory for pointer and all that
right?
In actual memory it will occupy
4 cells, yes. Correct.
It'll have 4 compartments,
right?
4 compartments it'll have.
Cool.
I hope you got some clarity.
Yeah.
So please again watch the
recordings.
Yeah.
So there are some traversals and
all this we will come back to
this later, right.
But again and again, I repeat,
yeah, we are slow in the
syllabus.
Yeah, because there are some
very basic doubts that come up,
but which is good.
Yeah.
We can take some extra class
also which is fine, but I would
urge to watch their recordings
right, watch their recordings
again and again and practice
things because that is the only
way to master it.
Yeah.
Otherwise, when I talk, it might
be looking OK, but later it
might be difficult.
So practice them right.
So all in sequence.
Meaning, what do you mean,
Vinay?
But yeah, for all of this,
that's pretty much so.
Thank you so much.
And again, sorry for, you know,
taking a class on the Sunday.
I didn't, you know, about this
semester starting.
I had to, you know, travel for
some conferences.
So from the next week, we will
always have only on Saturdays we
will not, you know, try to have
any, you know, extra Sundays and
all that.
Yeah, 16 classes.
Yeah, 16 classes are total.
We are already done with four,
so we just have, you know, or 12
more classes.
Yeah, NANDINI, Sir, can you
please go to the complete binary
tree slide?
I want to know whether like an
example is proper binary or not.
Yeah, you mean the original
complete binary tree?
One this one.
Yeah.
Is this proper?
All internal node have exactly
two.
Yeah, this is also proper.
This is also complete, but
there's not perfect because
these leaves are here.
These leaves are here.
Cool.
I'll stop the recording.
I'll stay for another two
minutes and for others.